how can we prevent our relationships
getting damaged Every Day brings with
its small challenges disappointments
frustrations and irritations that can
come between even the most committed
partners and subtly wears away at the
intensity of their connection
to prevent this risk lovers should
regularly make room to ask themselves in
a calm Spirit of gentleness openness and
curiosity two ostensibly simple yet
hugely Central and effective questions
firstly what are you angry with me about
secondly how have I scared you recently
let's look at the first question without
meaning to we are constantly angering
our partners by not being more of who
they would hope us to be
and it's critical that this anger can be
divulged and heard
so in answer to the first question we
might explain how we are angry that our
partners friends are so boring or they
don't have a better job or that they
leave the kitchen untidy or that they
worry so much about their mother and
they might get similarly angry with us
that we are so nervous or bad tempered
that we've been a stickler for manners
or that we judge other people harshly
we need not get angry while we divulge
our anger the mood can be Serene and
even playful we don't need Solutions or
magical answers either what really
counts is that we have a chance to let
go of our letdowns in an atmosphere of
understanding and mutual apology
then to turn to the second question love
can be subtly throttled by fear and
that's why we should ask how have I
scared you recently we scare each other
all the time by being unreasonable by
being messy by being unreliable and fear
erodes the trust that the small
vulnerable version of ourselves who
lurks within us needs from someone in
whom they choose to invest
there is in all of us a little child
looking for a safe mummy or daddy and
who probably privately recoiled when our
partners raised their voice with us or
didn't come home when they said they
would once more in talking about these
things what matters isn't that we never
cause an upset but that we should hear a
lover out politely when they tell us
sweetly and politely that we have done
so
we should stop denying our relationships
the routine kind of Maintenance that we
don't hesitate to Accord to a boiler or
an outboard engine
we don't have to dread the mysterious
end of relationships so long as we
regularly muster the courage to accept
how much we may have angered and
frightened Those whom we are committed
to loving